بعد نشر آرائه على الإنترنت
، قال العارض والممثل الروسي جان ميشيل شيرباك
إن والدته منعته عندما
قرر مغادرة البلاد ، أرسل لها
المال بينما أرسلت له في المقابل هذه
الرسالة
لا ترسل أي شيء سأرسله فقط أنا لا أفعل
لا تتواصل مع
رهاب روسيا والخونة
للوطن الأم ، أتمنى مخلصًا
أن تتخلى عن جواز سفرك الروسي
وتغادر هذا البلد في أي اتجاه ،
فأنت لم تعد ابني ، ولن يكون هناك
خونة في عائلتي ،
وينضم إلي جيدًا الآن هو جان ميشيل
scherbach ، إنه الآن في ألمانيا بعد
مغادرته روسيا
.
آسف لما حدث مع
والدتك ما جعلك تنشر
هذه الرسائل
علنًا جيدًا ، شكرًا لك على دعوتي لقد
تعلمت عن الأشياء التي تحدث في
روسيا
من أصدقائي لأن لدي الكثير من
الأصدقاء الذين يعيشون في أوكرانيا
واستيقظت واستيقظت في 24
فبراير ، فتحت هاتفي وتلقيت
رسائل من
عدد قليل
من أصدقائي من أوكرانيا وقالوا
إن
روسيا تقصف أوكرانيا الآن
، وها
أنا زرت أوكرانيا.  عدة
مرات عدة مرات في المرة الأخيرة التي كنت
فيها في الخريف
أه هذا العام
وما زلت لا أصدق أن
هذا يحدث
وبدأت أم صديقي في إرسال
الصور ومقاطع
الفيديو إلي النتائج الروسية
أم
الجيش الروسي أه
وقررت أن أنشره على إنستغرام الخاص بي
وأضعه أيضًا
وكأنني قمت بمزامنته مع
الدعاية الروسية معه ، لذلك
عندما تقول روسيا أن
الجيش الروسي
لا يهاجم
منطقة العقارات ، فقد قمت
بنشر أه
المنطقة المدمرة مع
الشقق والأشياء
نعم ، المثير للدهشة هو أنك
تمكنت من كسب
ثقة الكثير من الأوكرانيين الذين كانوا يروون
لك قصصهم عما كانوا يشاهدونه
على الأرض ، وكنت تنشر
ذلك جنبًا إلى جنب مع
وسائل الإعلام والدعاية الحكومية الروسية  د وأشخاص مثل
والدتك
كانوا يقولون إنك تعرف
كيف تعمل وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الروسية ، لقد بدأت حياتك
المهنية بالفعل في إحدى الشبكات ،
ما هو قوي جدًا بشأن جاذبيتها
للجمهور الروسي لدرجة أنه يمكنهم
تصديق
الأشياء التي قيلت لهم
على الرغم من سماعهم  أشياء
مختلفة تمامًا عن أفراد الأسرة
والأحباء في أوكرانيا
حسنًا ، إنه جنون ولكن أه الناس ليس
لديهم الفرصة
مثل الطرق
الجيدة للحصول على الأخبار من التلفزيون على سبيل المثال
لأن
أه كما تتذكر على الأرجح عندما روسيا
القادمة في
شبه جزيرة القرم
أه
يحبونهم هم  أه صنعت آخر
قناة تلفزيونية مستقلة أو ممسوكة
أه مغلقة وإه
عندما أه الناس في روسيا مثل في
ليسوا في المدن الكبيرة مثل
عمل القديس بطرس بموسكو الذي أه
الناس الذين يعيشون بعيدًا عن هذا
مثل من المدن الكبيرة أم
الكبيرة أه مدن أه
إنهم يضبطون على تلفازهم ويشاهدون
الدعاية ويستخدمون الدعاية الروسية فقط
، لذا فهم يعتقدون أن
وسائل الإعلام الرسمية أكثر من وسائل الإعلام
المستقلة وهم أيضًا جيدون.  الحكومة السعودية أه
عينت بعض وسائل الإعلام المستقلة
والصحفيين المستقلين أه
كوكلاء دوليين
لهذا
يؤمنون بها